Cheers indeed the town of
stratford-upon-avon is celebrating its
most famous son and thousands of
visitors are taking part even 450 years
after Shakespeare's birth his verses are
in common usage
Oh Lord we thought my pain it was to
drown what dreadful noise at Waterville
ideas but all the sites of death were in
mine eyes my horse my horse my kingdom
can breathe noise can see
stratford-upon-avon looks as it did when
Shakespeare wrote his dramas little is
known about his life except he was
baptized as the offspring of an ordinary
but well-to-do family he spent his
childhood and youth here before he
became a poet and playwright the best
the world has ever seen in the opinion
of many
Gregory Doran is one of them he's the
director of the famous Royal Shakespeare
Company his popularity is partly the
stories he tells and I think very young
children can be grabbed by stories of
faeries and shipwrecks and ghosts and
battles and witches and then later as
they grow through life they become
interested in Shakespeare for his
psychological insights or his political
the politics of the plays if you like
the ensemble has existed for more than
50 years after London Stratford is where
it plays most often famous British
actors like Judi Dench Ralph Fiennes and
Ben Kingsley have played roles in his
productions
at the birthday celebration ensemble
members show visitors some of the tricks
of the acting trade for example how do
you stage a fight one actor slaps his
hand the other ducks away life death and
love shakespeare's eternal themes he
doesn't judge he presents us in all our
human frailty and he doesn't take sides
it shows a huge panorama of society and
I think that's that that's his
extraordinary power that he makes you
decide he makes you put yourself into
the picture
some dispute that Shakespeare wrote all
of his 154 sonnets and 38 dramas I think
it is an attitude that's based on
snobbery I'm afraid that a simple
ordinary grammar school boy from here in
the West Midlands of England from from
Warwickshire from a simple country
market town like stratford-upon-avon
that somebody like that could have the
scale of reference and the humanity and
the compassion to to write a play I
don't really care who she he or they
were who wrote Shakespeare because we
have Shakespeare the people here in
Stratford see things the same way they
celebrate the bard
whose life and work have lost none of
their fascination and they really get
into it
well just look how many people are here
today to celebrate his four hundred and
fiftieth birthday so we needn't say
anything really he is popular the world
over we get to still get taught in the
same same room as he got taught him it's
very famous in China what's fantastic
it's nice to say people couldn't come
from all over the world to visit our
little town right there join themselves
the birthday procession ends here at
Holy Trinity Church where Shakespeare's
grave is located Shakespeare died in
Stratford supposedly on his 52nd
birthday but whether that's true remains
like so much about Shakespeare in the
realm of legend
you